And [unknown] that I'm not the only one that thinks regular expressions are
interesting and powerful, both West Weimer's 262 class and Peter Norwick's 212
class have entire units that are focused mostly on understanding and using
regular expressions. We're not going to go into that much depth now, but I'll
explain enough so you can understand basic regular expressions, including the
one that's used here. So, regular expressions define sets of strings. The
simplest is to just have a single character and that represents the set
containing just one string. So, for example, the regular expression A, defines a
set containing the single string just A. And I'm not writing my strings with
coats here or using Python set notation. I'm writing this in a more mathematical
way. We can also concatenate in. And if we have two regular expressions next to
each other, that gives us the set of everything we can get from R followed by
everything in S. This will make more sense when we have Rs and Ss that can
produce many strings. If it's just a followed by b, well, a can produce just a,
b can produce just b. So, give this a set containing the strings ab. We can put
multiple expressions within square braces like this and that produces a set of
strings which is the union of all the strings R can produce and all the strings
S can produce, so in this case this going to be a set of two elements containing
the strings a and b. We can use the asterisk, which means zero or more
occurrences of whatever precedes it. So, that would mean a star is the set of
strings, the empty string, the string a, the string aa, the string aaa, and so
on. Aaaa, and aaaaa. If we wrote that in Python, it would just be two quotes
next to each other. Since I'm not using the quotes here, I'll just write empty.
So a question mark is the set of two strings, either empty or the string a. The
last thing that I need to mention is that we can use parenthesis for grouping.
So, if you put parenthesis around two regular expressions, that becomes a single
expression, for example, if we had ab star that would be the set of strings a,
ab, abb, ab bb and so on. But if we use the parenthesis and we have ab
surrounded by parenthesis star, well that's going to be the set of strings
empty, abb bb and so on. The other thing parenthesis do is bind what's in
between them as variables. And so, the first input to our query is what's
contained in the first set of parenthesis.